so it's my honor to introduce our
graduation speaker and this is Scott
Beatson who has served a senior vice
president of applications at Yahoo in
this role he helped looked after yahoo
mail messenger flickin des groupes
answers as Umbra managing 600-plus
person organizations and over 600
million dollar revenue he joined yarn
207 with the acquisition of zimbra where
he was president and CTO prior to zimbra
he was CTO of ba systems we crafted the
technology and business strategy for
weblogic that drove be a problem 61
million to 1 billion in revenues and he
came to be a by the acquisition of
weblogic a pioneer in job and web
application technology he is also
credited with helping put together the
j2ee standard launching the web
application server category launching
the java community process and driving
web services with microsoft and IBM
prior to her magic he was a transact
developer of distributed transaction
information sharing systems acquired by
IBM I guess you notice a pattern there
start it have it acquired started have
it acquired and that's probably useful
advice and he may talk a bit about that
we're proud to call him a fellow
Carnegie Mellon family member he did his
PhD ms and computer science and
bachelors in applied mathematical
science it's really my pleasure to
introduce Scott Dietzen now entrepreneur
out of residence
Thank You margin and thank you faculty I
am both honored and happy to be here and
congratulations to the Carnegie Mellon
in Silicon Valley class of 2010 as far
as i know i only had one recurring dream
it's a nightmare that goes like this
it's senior finals week and I've
completely forgotten to attend a couple
of classes I've not done the assignments
not taking the tests and I'm not going
to graduate it astounds me that this
nightmare still has the capacity to
scare me some 20 years on but the good
news for all of you is that forever more
you can sigh with relief and roll over
and go back to sleep my aspiration for
my few minutes with you here today is to
share some thoughts on how to have a
successful career in technology and as
is my modus operandi I have a top 10
list the ARPANET is almost 40 years old
the world wide web is approaching 20 and
yet their impact on the world continues
apace most of you will not remember how
things were before hand if you can
you're getting a bit longer the to
deflect me I only started programming in
college in those days we programmed in
the middle of the night because it was
the only time we could get sufficient
cycles that a simple build wouldn't
bring our shared computer to its knees
most of us would sleep through class or
else in class in order to get the vastly
higher productivity we could get in the
middle of the night consider the
contrast my son who's now 3 has been
teaching himself the iPad a machine with
more memory and more horsepower than
that refrigerator-sized mini computer
that I got my start up he has no written
language yet but he has learned how to
navigate menus through pattern matching
and trial and error and while he's not
programming he plays with gaming and
education applications has books read to
him and watch his videos unbeknownst to
daddy he even discovered a mash-up of
Thomas the Train and rapper 50 cent
and he's now a master of the touchscreen
so much so that he'll walk up to a
laptop or a TV and hit it and expect it
to do his bidding why is the TV broken
daddy accessibility to computing via DS
true consumer devices smartphones and
tablets is going to continue to
transform our industry helping to make
the associated software easy and elegant
is going to be one of the best things
you can do in retrospect we take them so
much for granted that it is hard for us
to comprehend the simple elegance and
dramatic impact of the spreadsheet or
the hyperlink or the touchscreen none of
us is likely to come up with anything
quite so profound but each of you has
the opportunity to help change the world
for the better and to be handsomely
rewarded for doing so when I return to
the other CMU CMU East a couple of years
ago for a celebration of 50 years of
working computing happily I'm young
enough that i missed the first couple of
decades i was startled to hear gross the
worry that our discipline was getting
bored that perhaps all the revolutionary
work had been done this is silly I've
now been in Silicon Valley for going on
15 years and unconvinced that the breath
breath of innovation going on today is
higher than it's ever been five years
ago venture capitalists weren't
investing much in databases or file
systems or programming languages and
today there's exciting work going on
lower the barriers for delivering
innovation and technology have never
been lower so two more firmly without
any sewing this about our industry
getting stale I humbly offer a top ten
list of ongoing disruptive waves that
will keep computing both exciting and
lucrative for the next decade and beyond
number one mobile in the next few years
html5 capable mobile devices will trump
pcs as the primary internet interface
and sometime thereafter we will get the
majority of humanity online
number two blended realities as we play
social games run run into friends with
some help from Foursquare compare
athletic performance on strava or just
find a good coffee shop along the way to
our destination we are artfully mixing
virtual worlds and good old reality and
exciting new ways number three social in
addition to being a new vehicle to
interconnect people social networks are
changing the way we deal with
information just as search did before it
not always for the better I might add
who are all these people with nothing
better to do than update their facebook
status of eating sushi or going to the
bathroom number four cloud we are
stitching together tens and even
hundreds of thousands of commodity
machines and discs to cost effectively
deliver seemingly unlimited computing
power but the software still has to
evolve to take advantage of that
elasticity number five software is a
service why should end users have to
worry about preparing deploying managing
securing and updating software expect
software services to get ever more
specialized and expect integration to
happen happen at scale between the SAS
providers number six collaboration in
the large that is across organizational
geographic cultural and even language
boundaries wiki's and crowdsourcing are
transforming content just as open source
and agile methodologies transform
software number seven big data we are
crunching vast quantities of data in
these clouds to improve the user
experience of search social networking
ecommerce and so on like Moore's Law our
data footprint is doubling every 18
months but we are a long way from mining
the smarts buried inside that data
number eight functional programming and
no sequel we re exploring functional
programming languages see closure and
Scala functional programming models like
mapreduce that I learned many many years
ago and function
representations all to make it easier
for programmers to deliver massively
distributed massively parallel
applications number nine artificial
intelligence like functional programming
AI is making a comeback more
intelligence particularly machine
learning is being incorporated into
software to make it better as well as
more resilient in the face of change one
point I find compelling is seeing use
win in the darpa grand challenge and
finally number ten ubiquitous computing
software is finally making inroads in
areas that have historically not been
well automated such as medical care or
managing the power group we are even
recasting whole disciplines like
astronomy and particle physics as big
data problems we're going to be
published so much data that only
software can meaningfully digest it
generate one of my heroes calls this the
fourth paradigm of science so that's my
top 10 list of disruptors shaking up
computing as you look toward optimizing
your own contributions to and rewards
from our industry keep these ways of
transformation in mind it is through
their impact that technologies will be
made and obsoleted and fortunes won and
lost consider there would have been no
weblogic without the advent of the web
java and the free trial download by
empowering every developer to try out a
product every day we were able to push
off corporate purchasing until after the
applications were built today who is
much less shelf where in the world
because of business rarely expects to
have proven out software before they pay
for and consider it would have been no
zumba without their richly interactive
web UI of Ajax mashups open source and
the innovative business model of mixing
an open-source core with proprietary
extensions now called open court
catching one or more of these
transformative waves can give the
software you right the leverage to
change the world
but it doesn't change the fundamentals
most of all you need a great product a
great team behind that product and a set
of customers that need your products so
badly that they will spend their time
and scarce money to adopt it there is
still a staggering amount of mediocrity
and software which means frustration and
waste for end-users talk to your
customers and use the web to help them
talk to you they will help you do better
finally these top 10 disruptors
especially with all the others I haven't
sorted out yet are going to remake the
tech industry landscape yet again ten
years ago Google hadn't made its first
dollar from search advertising Apple had
been written off for dead and Facebook
hadn't been born our industry stays in
this state of flux because of innovation
but also because some of our best
thinkers keep getting it wrong we had
weblogic made one right back in
believing Giada would find more of a
home on the server than on the client in
the browser the smart money then was on
Java clients and C++ serves but at zumba
I was really troubled by the idea of
trying to write a hundred thousand lines
of Model View controller code in
JavaScript and figuring out how to run
it inside the browser and yet that was
probably the best decision that we made
when I first looked at wow I rarely
stopped you know why try to reinvent the
internet for mobile but when apps showed
up in mobile devices i'd propose that
you know on the pc apps had lost out to
the browser and i was even more
convinced it would play out that way in
mobile how wrong I was keep these
failures of prognostication in mind as
they create an opportunity for you to
make contrary and bets and win big let
me close with a story back in the early
days of Java I had the opportunity to
represent weblogic in a back room debate
among the job of powers that be I made
what I thought was a well-reasoned
argument my case was summarily dismissed
by one of the Sun representatives who
closed his response with and Scott just
why in the hell would you think that
would ever work I paused thought and
said I guess I'm just a blind stupid
optimist
at that point one of my allies in the
debate said laughing gee Scott I sure
hope you don't lose your optimism
because then you're just going to be
blind and stupid I can no longer recall
what that particular debate was about
but I still laugh about the blind and
stupid bit there's an underlying truth
in this story if you aspire to lead
people and after all developing software
leisure leaders as our mantra here at
CMU undying contagious optimism is an
essential asset cultivate it just try
not to be blind and stupid as reading
said there is no limit to what you can
accomplish if you don't care who gets
the credit your goal should be to help
build teams that work well enough
together that you forget who came up
with what idea perhaps the single
greatest thing about our industry is
what a small team of bright passionate
people can accomplish smartphones open
source and clouds have dramatically
reduced the hurdles to delivering the
next generation of software innovation
you just need to come up with a spark
thank you good luck and Godspeed to the
card email in class of 20